hello my name is Peter mark Baer word
I'm the head of migration architecture
here at Google cloud and what I'd like
to do today is talk to you a little bit
about ways you can accelerate your
migration towards the cloud and what I'd
like to do is just to start off by
explaining how we view IT applications
and where they reside essentially in the
world of migration and so if you look at
this chart you can see that all
applications really fall very broadly
into these four quadrants whether
they're on the cloud or not and greater
or lesser degrees of modernization and
so when we think about where customers
are going and where customers would want
to be from the point of view of the
cloud provider we're hoping that
everyone would like to be in that top
quadrant with the highlighted green area
and we really think that that's actually
the best location for applications to go
where they're the most efficient where
they're this where they're secure where
they are have cost certainty and cost
efficiency and so we really do believe
that that's the best place for
applications to go however we recognize
that in reality most applications
actually reside in that bottom left
quadrant where they still sit inside of
data centers they maybe haven't been
modernized they're using older
architectural patterns and they aren't
se decoupled they aren't highly
efficient and not containerized and so
on and in reality most customer
applications actually do sit there today
and so as a cloud provider what we have
to do is really come to where customers
are today and that's something that
Google cloud is really strive to do in
the last couple of years is not just say
there here's this lofty goal of cloud
and we hope you guys get there but that
actually we're going to be providing
tools and methods and best practices to
be able to go from this bottom left to
the top right and if you look at this
chart really there are essentially two
paths from the bottom left to the top
right either you can move over and
modernize applications and refactor them
and so on and leave them inside the data
center and then move up to the cloud or
you can move up from the data center
into the cloud with relatively static
applications that don't change
too much in that transition and then
slowly transition them over to the right
side as you modernize and refactor and
rewrite applications and so we feel that
both of these routes are valid and both
of them have paths of success that you
could do
however today what we're going to do is
focus on that the path where you go up
in over first because the reality is
customers are customers and customer
applications are actually really
everywhere on this quadrant very few
people are sitting in just one quadrant
people have applications and data
centers moved applications out of data
centers into the cloud and move them
over into the cloud they've modernised
inside the data center and there's
generally speaking a very widespread of
applications everywhere and so there are
many many paths of success in migration
and we're just going to focus on just
for today on moving those applications
that sit in data centers and moving them
up into the cloud as they are and so
kind of an open question to this
audience here if you've ever worked on a
migration to the cloud from say a data
center what kind of challenges did you
have I'm sure there were many and so I
along with many others here at Google
cloud who have worked on other
migrations sat down and kind of
brainstorm what were the top 10
challenges that we came across we've had
a fairly obvious trend that came up and
that they were really cut in half by
technical challenges and businesses
business challenges we're really things
that slow down acceleration and lowered
our chance of success so if we go
through these and we look at these
business challenges these mostly have to
do with people and getting the right
people and having the right people buy
into the idea of a migration and really
see that it's going to be successful for
the company and these are the kinds of
problems that really you know can't be
solved by writing a script or an
application or deploying some new
version of something or other this is
really about people believing that the
migration is the best thing for the
company and that Google Cloud is the
best place to go and we've encountered
these sort of situations but these
situations
that you encounter they really do can't
they really beg your pardon they really
can slow down your migration so if you
look at things like in particular this
first these first two bullets where
maybe management doesn't believe 100% in
the migration that can really impede a
lot of progress or if people are
expecting the moon and really you're
going into low orbit for example that
can really slow down the pace of a
migration or in fact when different
groups have different ideas of what
exactly the migration is supposed to
accomplish and so being clear about what
it's what you're trying to do and who
needs to be involved and who needs to
support this is so important for having
a successful migration and this is the
kind of thing that as a provider we can
do quite a bit to help people convince
senior management we can work with
different groups across your company to
be able to describe the benefits of what
a migration is and what Google cloud can
do and they're also several programs
that we offer from different groups
within our company that actually try to
address these situations upfront in a
programmatic way but at the end of the
day most of the business challenges are
really about people rather than
technical issues on the other hand there
are always technical issues with any
technical project of course they're
going to be technical issues and we
encounter these frequently as well but
it's important to recognize them for
what they are so you can start
preventing them from happening if you
can as you start on your migration
project so that you don't encounter the
the issues that we've had where we have
had migration projects really slowed
down because some things that maybe we
didn't foresee at the time so things
like automation really speed up
migration the more that you invest in
automation and so we've noticed that
across customers that we've encountered
where the more automated customers are
already and the more of an automation
culture they have the easier the
migration becomes and the more that you
can do that before you migrate the
easier your migration will become and I
think the second point is actually
probably one of the more important ones
we often get say the opposite reaction
of people who are not enthusiastic we
get people are extremely enthusiastic
about migrating which is fantastic but
then you come into a situation where
they want to do
absolutely everything all at once and
you get a bit of a feature creep
situation where people just want to add
more and more and more to this project
and it becomes kind of untenable it
becomes undoable and then instead of
actually doing this grand ambitious
effort actually it gets all pulled back
into in the worst case scenario nothing
at all and so there has to be some sort
of limits on what is realistic to do in
a particular time frame and what needs
to be accomplished we've gone into
customers that have for example had say
a very large my sequel back-end database
they were really enthusiastic about not
only moving to the cloud but say let's
reconsider my sequel maybe we should
move to a different kind of database
maybe we should move to manage databases
like cloud sequel or we should try no
sequel database maybe we could shard out
the the data structure into different
kinds of databases we have to caution
them against doing that during the
migration said look we have a specific
timeline to accomplish what you need to
accomplish here let's get through that
and then after you're migrated you can
reconsider your design options and look
at your database in a kind of calmer
sort of atmosphere and once they did
that they actually saw the benefit of
doing that once the migration was
finished it was finished successfully
then they took the time to actually
examine what were their database needs
in a way that didn't impact the
migration and they actually had a much
more reasoned conversation among
themselves about how to migrate that
particular component and so it's really
important if you've got a big enthusiasm
build-up which is fantastic not to get
too carried away and so these technical
challenges are things that we try to
address with technical solutions but
there are things that you want to watch
out for it because they really do slow
down accelerate it beg your pardon slow
down
migrations and so when we look at what
slows down or decelerates migrations we
also want to talk to you about what
would accelerate a migration we think
this is where our best practices really
come into play and this is really what
we want to focus on for the rest of this
talk about what accelerates your
migration what moves it forward about
what can help you and so these are best
practices again gathered from
different co-workers that I have and
myself on the actual best practices that
we have learned from working with
customers so this is something that is
practical experience that we have seen
actually doing the act of migrating and
so I think the most important one and
this is what we're gonna spend most of
the time on is building a proper cloud
foundation we're gonna go into that in
quite a bit more detail so I'm gonna
leave that for now while you're building
your cloud foundation and throughout
your migration the next most important
thing to do is actually think about
security the whole time so this is not
something that you think about at the
beginning is not something you think
about the end this is part of every
single step of a migration otherwise
it's really just not going to work
you're going to have either people
complaining we're gonna have things that
are not secure or worse of both worlds
you're gonna have both and so it's very
important to make that a consideration
while you do your entire migration the
whole time as I said before automation
can really improve a migration the more
that you can do it the faster and easier
it can be it's the difference between
having to manually copy say an entire
application or maybe an entire operating
system from one location to another
verifying that the copy happen correctly
copying over data making sure the tests
run making sure the application is
connected the same way versus just
saying you know I'm going to redeploy
this application from one location to
another you're talking about the
difference between hours versus minutes
or even days versus minutes the more you
can automate and so everything you can
do to automate your infrastructure and
your environments is only going to help
third I beg your pardon fourth the more
you can prepare for change in the more
you can slice up your migration into
manageable chunks the easier it will be
so if you can build it relatively on
your migration plan if you can say these
steps are gonna happen and then build on
those steps and just be prepared for one
step to influence another step in a way
that you didn't expect you're gonna be
much better suited and better prepared
for success rather than having one two
three steps maybe have like one through
twenty one through fifty whatever it is
smaller more manageable steps in that
way you can adjust as you go along as
you're making this migration perhaps
first time we've done this and you
really need to watch what you're doing
and how you're getting there and how
it's moving so you really don't want to
be too rigid in your plan so be prepared
for change it'll be it'll work out
pretty well and then finally once you're
migrated you're not really done that's
just the first step of actually existing
on the cloud and having an application
there so really you need to prepare for
what we call day two so day one is this
migration day two is this application
now exists in a new environment it needs
to be managed and you need to monitor it
you need to log it you need to audit it
redeploy new versions and so on so you
need to prepare to manually operate this
not manually but you need to actually
operate this application as it exists in
the cloud so you need to prepare for
that as you migrate now I said I was
going to go back to what a cloud
foundation is and how important this is
in terms of the best practice and so
we're gonna dive into that a little bit
more and so creating a cloud foundation
is really about creating the location
where your applications are going to
migrate before you migrate a single
application and the the reason this is
so important is that if you can properly
migrate into an already created and
already vetted and already secure are
already properly built out foundation
it's gonna make the migration
significantly easier rather than trying
to do that as you migrate your
application is very much kind of like
trying to build a plane while you're
trying to fly the plane you really want
to have this foundation set before the
first migration happens and then once
that migration happens you don't have to
think about all these parts that of the
foundation that exists you can just keep
on migrating applications learning
what's unique about your application
about your company about your setup
rather than having to figure out what is
unique about this cloud environment that
you're moving to which is really what
you're figuring out when you establish
your cloud foundation so if we look at
the first one and it's really I this is
not say rocket science kind of makes
sense that the first thing you should do
is pick the first application that you
want to move but picking that
application can be very difficult and it
can be non-intuitive or maybe perhaps
not even obvious if you haven't done
this before so the characteristics of
say a good mover
is something that is not going to bring
the business down if it doesn't work on
the other hand it can't be so far out of
the relevancy of the business that it's
not going to be important if it does
move so you want things that are still a
working application of business
application something that matters it's
not a POC it's not just a throwaway
application it is something real but is
not something that is going to break the
application or break your business I beg
your pardon but you still have to learn
from it you still have to have some sort
of knowledge gained from it and also you
have to be able to control it so if it's
a license that you don't control if
there's particular hardware or software
that connects to it that you can control
that's not something that's going to
make a good first mover if you look at
the technical characteristics they're
similar in theme you don't want
something that's so tied to the rest of
the business from a technical standpoint
that's gonna be hard to untangle you
don't want something that's so
intertwined with software licenses it's
gonna be difficult to move you want
something that can cleanly move on its
own as easily as possible rather than
something that's really wound up inside
of many many other things and so if we
look at say an example application where
we have users and external applications
connecting to a website and a mobile
application there's a logging system
there's blog posts and so on some sort
of say customer commentary system if you
for example it could be a lot of things
and if we look at this whole system what
would be a good first mover for example
this mobile application doesn't really
depend on much of the rest of the
application stack it's got pretty simple
inputs and outputs and it can be pulled
out and put in a different application
location fairly easily and so this would
make a pretty good example of a first
mover on the other hand bad first movers
are pretty much the opposite of
everything else we suggest that things
that are deeply entangled with the rest
of the application stack licenses that
don't lend themselves to being migrated
things that are either far too business
critical to move first or things that
are so irrelevant that they don't really
prove anything
edge cases that are again so far out
there that there
going to be relevant for the rest of
your application base don't particularly
make good first movers and so if we look
again at the same application stack this
blog post pool that kind of sits in the
middle of everything would be really
difficult to move first it's got so many
connections to everything else so many
dependencies on data in an upstream and
downstream systems it would just be so
much more challenging than picking a
different application so it would be
much more difficult application to move
first next you want to establish an
identity on the cloud so people are
going to be using your cloud environment
your users your developers operations
and so on you need to establish who
those people are and how they are going
to get access and what those identities
actually mean and as far as Google cloud
is concerned we have different
identities which are either people their
groups or their service accounts so they
are automated systems acting in certain
ways and they become identities and
those I am a bigger part lives become
roles and those roles have permission to
act on certain services and so you've
got a great deal of granularity and
flexibility and how you want to set that
up in order to do pretty much anything
you need to do in the cloud and so if
you look at the types of identities that
we have in the cloud you've got actual
people you know human accounts versus
service accounts which are not human
those are robotic accounts automated
accounts however you would like to
describe them you have groups and then
finally domains and these are all the
different ways that identity comes
together in the cloud and the really key
thing here that I would like you to take
away from this is that there are a
couple ways of setting this up and we
try to be as flexible as we can in order
to meet you where you are if you don't
have a current identity system then you
can set that up in the cloud you can set
that up with Google Cloud or if you
already have an existing one then you
can synchronize that with the cloud and
so that it maintains your existing
identity structure but the point is that
we want to meet you with what you need
and what do you have today
third organizing your resources is
critical so once you have decided what
is going to move you've decided who are
your people and what
rolls gonna be in the cloud deciding how
you're going to organize your cloud is
very important in Google cloud you can
have an organization with a number of
folders underneath it within these
folders you can add projects and the
projects actually hold the resources
things like virtual machines databases
queues and so on and so there's a
layering of organization that you can
add and how you decide to do this really
depends on your organizational
preferences I mean we have a number of
ideas and suggestions but it's really
going to depend on what suits your
company best so if we take a look at say
maybe the simplest way of organizing a
company you have an organization at the
top then you have folders for
environments and then applications
underneath the great thing about this is
fairly soon as simple its intuitive does
not get complicated very soon how on the
downside this is not something that
lends itself to flexibility if you have
environments that don't quite fit in
here if you have things like shared
services you have no acknowledgement of
the different divisions within a company
so if you take a slightly more
complicated view you could say let's
organize at a second level by function
so you have applications you have shared
services and then underneath relatively
similar structure and so the downside is
you're getting a little more complicated
the upside is you've got a little more
flexibility in terms of adding shared
services recognizing that there are
different functions of applications so
you can add that and then finally if we
look at say maybe the most complex
recommendation that we start with you're
actually dividing up applications by
division before you get down to function
or environment and the upside of this is
you get fantastic flexibility you can
really define and describe your
organization in Google cloud the way it
actually is reflected in reality the
downside is that it is much more
complicated to manage it's much more
complicated even to visualize and
conceptualize and crossing different
project barriers and different folder
barriers may in fact be more difficult
but it's all going to depend on the plus
and minus of what you want what works
best for you and so there are different
ways of doing that we're capable of
supporting whatever those are but it's
important for you to decide what works
best for you
next once you have this foundation
created so the you've created or you've
selected your first mover already you've
decided who your people are going to be
when they're in their cloud decided what
that organization is going to look like
and then next you actually need to group
those individuals and resources together
so that you can figure out who's going
to do what when how to whomever so this
is an example grouping that we could
recommend for groups starting out in the
cloud and the first one you want to have
a group that's going to define and
control how your organization is defined
and what permissions you're gonna give
to everyone where is everyone going to
go what is gonna be at the top level
what are the things that you're going to
decide to do and so this group is only
going to decide what things are and what
things can be within the organization
ideally they're going to does decide
very little else so you want to have
separation of duties as clearly as
possible next you could have an
in-network administration group in this
group as you may assume it's going to
define how the network works they're
gonna define what kind of networks
you're gonna use where the firewalls
who's gonna have access to what how are
you going to make connections between
different projects but different
networks cloud to data center and so on
and they're gonna decide that and once
again you're gonna want to have a narrow
focus on that so that is all that that
group is responsible for same idea with
security where you're gonna have
security group or security administrator
group define what is permissible for the
different roles what is permissible with
the different networks what is
permissible say from a virtual machine
and that it's the sole focus of what
they are going to do and then finally
say actually a very common grouping is
actually billing so people who are
responsible for how the company gets
built how the individual divisions
within the company are going to get
charged back based on the total cloud
bill and so on and that is their sole
focus and that is a set of permissions
that you can sequester off from
everything else where they're only
looking at how the bills come in where
they're coming from who is charging what
and who is spending so much and these
are really just
getting started recommendations or a lot
more flexibility and a lot more
granularity that you could add over time
but these are strong recommendations
that we have up front then finally the
last step of building out this
foundation is really defining your
network so you have a first mover you
have people and identities you have an
organization structure you have
groupings for permissions and roles and
responsibilities and finally you need to
really define the network that these
applications are gonna live in and what
your network wants to be and what you
need it to be for your company and for
your applications to succeed so the
first thing you need to decide is how
you're going to connect to Google so if
you have existing infrastructure already
you're going to have to pick some kind
of connectivity option up front whether
that's going over the public Internet
whether that's going over carrier
peering so partnering with some of our
partners to be able to carry to create
leased lines over carriers or directly
peering with Google ourselves and so
these options are all available to you
they have greater or lesser degrees of
cost and speed so it really depends on
what you need and how long you need it
for none of these options have to last
forever so something you could start
with going over the public internet
creating a VPN or you can move direct
into direct peering over time and then
scale that back down it really depends
on what you need and how long you need
it for so if you look at some of these
different options if you look at say
going over the public internet and
peering at an ISP if you look at the on
the left-hand side here you're getting
on yours your side you've got an SLA
between yourself and the peering
equipment at the ISP and you've got
capacity management between the ISP and
a Google peering location meanwhile if
you do direct peering you're actually
directly peering with Google at an
exchange room in a data center or
something like that in appearing
location with us and so you're cutting
out actually a lot more steps in between
and you've got more direct connectivity
you can pay for higher bandwidth to be
able to enable that as well
and once you've got connectivity to
Google you've got to decide what is your
network going to look like what regions
are you going to use are you going to be
localized to say a region that's closest
to you are you going to use multiple
regions so you can use all regions
Google Network span all regions by
default and so you've got to decide in
terms of operations where are you going
to choose to deploy applications where
are you going to choose to deploy
virtual machines and how do you connect
these different networks if you have
multiple Network so a strategy we've
seen for many many years has been a
hub-and-spoke where you've got at the
hub you've got shared services and in
the spokes you've got the different
application different environments that
can connect into the shared services and
still have separation of concerns out in
there in the spokes where you're
connecting between the hub and spoke
over VPN or if you're doing Network
peering Google has also introduced what
we call shared VPC networks where you
have a single V PC a single network that
is say administered by the network
administration group and other projects
have permission to launch resources
within specific subnets in that group
inside that network and so this is a
different way of doing shared services
that doesn't involve period doesn't
involve VPNs if you need to have shared
services if you need to have still
separation of concern and separation of
ownership of resources but you want
applications still deployed within the
same network and so we've seen customers
have a lot of success with this and so
that's the end of my recommendations is
the end of the five steps of the cloud
foundation again these are kind of built
out over time and experience of what we
have done with customers but we strongly
recommend that really building out that
foundation is going to lead you to so
much more success and actually have a
better chance of moving your migrations
forward more quickly by doing this for
lack of a better term homework upfront
if you've really build that out if you
take the time to invest in what this
needs to be then you're gonna have a
great deal more success
so thank you and we're gonna have
questions in just a few minutes so
please stay stick around
you
hello welcome back thank you for these
questions I'm sure there are plenty more
what we'll try to do afterwards is get
to those questions and answer them
offline but we've selected six here that
seem to touch on a few similar concepts
and questions so I'm going to go through
those and hopefully answer
what do you bands ask me here this first
question what open-source tools can help
with automation there are a lot and it
really kind of depends on what point in
your deployment pipeline you're talking
about would you have everything from
right at the beginning to right at the
very end so I'm gonna run through just a
few so if you look at software that
helps you with your continuous
integration side of things you've got a
lot of things that plug into Jenkins so
Jenkins is really kind of fantastic
controller for that side of the pipeline
where you're integrating different
points of say deployments a code that's
committed to get or kind of wherever you
keep your code and being able to package
that up being able to run integration
tests unit tests whatever those are and
then deploying that out as well and
integrating along that along that aside
from from from Jenkins into something
like say using configuration tools like
chef and puppet and so on really
actually make it fairly easy to have a
situation where you have a developer
that can commit to a shared repository
for whatever project Jenkins knows that
new things have come in can run
integration tests and then deploy that
bias a safe chef or whatever you would
like to use and be able to deploy that
onto virtual machines you can integrate
all that with say a cloud native
environment configuration tool like
deployment manager or an open-source
equivalent something like terraform
where you've got terraform or deployment
manager managing the actual resources
and something like chef and puppet
managing the configuration of your
applications on those resources if you
want to use containers then certainly
things like you know kubernetes which is
open source I mean it was created at
Google but it is definitely open source
is a great container management
orchestration tool seems to be fairly
popular these days and so if you are
using containers then you want to have a
container orchestration tool also
managing that a second question how to
encourage a culture of automation to
accelerate migration that's actually a
fantastic question
I actually firmly believe that
automation is one of the best ways to
accelerate migration and so this is
really important I think one of the
things to do is that to sell IT and
development on the idea that automation
doesn't just help migration it helps
developers no matter where they're
deploying to it helps IT it helps
operations
it helps security because you can
basically take all these steps that are
potentially manual at this point and
codify them you can put them into code
and commit them you can audit them you
can look at them you can see what the
processes are what the procedures are to
be able to improve them to be able to
see what is actually done and you're
taking all this operational overhead off
of people who are doing this manually
and so there are huge benefits well
beyond migration and one of the other
nice things about automation is actually
it's not an all-or-nothing proposition
you don't go from a completely manual to
manually deployed pipeline to a fully
automated one in one step there's baby
steps you can take all along the way and
these incremental baby steps have huge
benefits at every single step if all you
want to do is move to say automated
configuration management with say
ansible then do that and you will see
huge benefits even if you're not fully
automated down further up the pipeline
you're still going to get a lot of
benefit or from the other side if you
just want to implement Jenkins so that
every time you commit to your repository
you're running some tests that has huge
benefits right there already and so I
think the two-pronged approach towards
going to a culture of automation is one
everyone needs to understand this is not
just for migration it benefits
day-to-day operations of all of IT and
to baby steps are hugely beneficial you
don't have to do all or nothing to be
able to really benefit from automation
that's a third question what is the best
way to
get started with the migration I think
you've got to have a reason so why do
you want to move if you're in a data
center are you capacity constrained are
you not happy with your current
equipment is upgrading the equipment
going to be too expensive are you at an
end of a lease is there a reason why
wherever you are currently deployed is
not working well because that's often a
great motivating factor on the other
hand is there something in particular
about moving to Google cloud that is
particularly enticing is there something
very interesting it's about say machine
learning or using kubernetes on Google
cloud that is particularly enticing so I
think getting a good reason for why you
want to migrate is absolutely important
and so once you have that reason this is
the thing that kind of overcomes those
business challenges that I was talking
about earlier about motivating people
and getting people convinced that this
is the best thing to do for your company
is the best way to get started so really
finding that motivating reason and
getting out there and pushing people to
be able to start that migration is a
good way to start next question
what resources are available from Google
and Google's partners to assist with our
migration so I'll speak about us first
we have tools that are available things
like say data transfer tools so you can
send us data offline you can do use data
transfer tools to transfer data from
kind of wherever it sits and to say
Google Cloud Storage you can work with
us on like DM migration where we have a
VM migration tool we also have like I
said programs so things like if you work
with our professional services team they
have several migration programs that can
help you move forward and so those are
kind of the defined specifically for
migration tools that you can use from us
in addition to that working with Google
Account teams and so on will certainly
enable those migrations they'll help you
out in kind of whatever way and connect
you in to the various different groups
at Google that can help you with that in
terms of our partners we have a lot of
technical partners like say cloud in
your villa strata that are
all kind of geared towards automating
migrations and migration tooling a
tunity works on data migration so we
have a few of those we work with large
partners that will come in and assist
you kind of in terms of Human Resources
moving your applications moving your
data and we partner with a lot of those
and so you can go everywhere from
looking at say our resources online and
reading up documentation to implementing
our tools working with us working with
partners or any kind of combination
thereof and we do that fairly frequently
I've done that many many times myself
everything from only working with
Googlers to only working with partners
and like I said everything in between
question five the shared VPC project
apply to both public and private subnets
for private subnets what's the model for
accessing the resource so the first
question yeah in a in a shared B PC you
can make public and private subnets it's
really very much dependent on kind of
what sort of shared VPC you want it's
under the control of that the admin for
that shared VPC if you want all the 7s
to be private you can do that one none
of them some sort of mix you can do that
for private subnets what's the model for
accessing the resource I'm not entirely
sure I get the question but I'll try to
answer it the way shared B PCs work is
that there is a project that owns the V
PC the shared V PC and it gives
permission out to other projects to
launch resources within that V PC within
a subnet and so if you've decided that
this subnet is going to be a private
subnet and that project a has permission
to launch resources launch VMs within
that subnet it's going to be able to
have total control over that and then
the network admin so the the admin of
the shared V PC is going to determine
how the different subnets are allowed to
interact with each other whether they're
gonna be totally fire walled off whether
they're gonna have some access between
each other or if it's going to be
completely open its kind of determined
by that network admin and then finally I
guess it's kind of related please
clarify the shared V PC network so you
can touch on that one
more so like I said shared VPC is a VPC
owned by a particular project it's
administered by a particular project the
idea being though that that project is
not going to launch any resources itself
it is a way to collect Network
administration in within a single
project and be able to distribute that
network out to different projects that
can then launch resources and so the
scenario that this is built for and
we've seen this with quite a few
companies is that network
administrator's need to control what
happens in the network but developing
teams are relatively autonomous and own
the resources that they have they deploy
shoot bigger partner so I I'm sorry I
lost my train of thought there and so
when the deployment team or the the
development team deploys resources they
want to be able to own that and be able
to control that and be able to say this
is what we want to do and this is not
what we want to do with our resources
but also we don't want to administer our
own Network we want the network admin
team to be able to handle that we just
want to create and be able to control
our own resources and so that is kind of
the goal in the idealized situation what
a shared VPC is used for there are
actually a lot more use cases for that
in particular for shared services where
it comes up a lot but the case being
most of the time it's when teams own the
resources when they own the applications
where they own the services that are
deployed but do not want to or should
not own the actual network
administration is really what it's
getting gerd for and that is it for our
questions and so thank you very much
thank you for joining me and next
session is coming up shortly thank you
very much
you